what was it like for you watching
brian cranston's like resurgence with
you know you know
not
like
no lie he's the greatest human being
alive
like as an actor as a person like you'd
show up every single day and you know
when you do something every day you kind
of like you can get annoyed with
already
never he was so happy like to be there
and so great to the crew and so great to
everyone so in my head he's uh like my
idol because i'd like people to say that
same thing about me but
no one deserves it more never mind the
fact that he's an incredible actor i
mean he's done now so many different
things and
i don't i don't
think anyone can beat him you keep in
touch with them still you know it's
funny
i don't know you know people you're on
your shows with or whatever like
you always go oh we're going to stay
best friends forever right everyone kind
of says that like summer camp you go to
summer camp we're going to write each
other every single day we're going to be
best friends and then you go home and
everyone kind of starts living their
life and
you just kind of forget brian reaches
out to me
every two weeks and he has for 15 years
wow
like literally reaches out to just
checking on you hope you're well what
are you up to like he's literally
hollywood god
and he's he calls me he's [ __ ]
heisenberg you know he's the best i'm a
piece of [ __ ]
me too dude every time i see a friend
i'm like dude why don't i call you like
i'm so sorry i've never reached out to
anybody right yeah i mean here's the
thing too that i'll i'll have a little
thought to myself like oh you know
like i should reach out to somebody just
getting stoked you know i mean it'd be
make me feel good if i like and i have
that thought and then it just
flutters away and i don't do anything
and then you check your social media how
many likes you got in the last place
they don't pick up it's like well i
tried like
now i'm never gonna try for two years
yeah
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never been allowed to do for jackass and
a lot of it is flagrantly illegal so
it's adults only and if you live in any
of these states then you better go to
stevo.com and check out my tour schedule
hurry up and get your tickets too
because it's selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]